república centroafricana vive hoy con el
corazón en un puño el domingo celebra
sus presidenciales y legislativas pero
esta jornada electoral está lejos de
enmendar la crisis de poder y su
consiguiente violencia
el actual presidente tu a vera ha
prometido eliminar la sierre elegido en
frente tiene una oposición con 15
candidatos ya una serie de grupos
armados que controlan dos tercios del
territorio
hay que ponerse a todos los combates que
ocurren en el interior del país y que
vienen hasta la capital debemos decir no
así que este domingo el 27 levántate no
tengas miedo escoge a quien quieras
escoge a tu presidente para evitar que
alcancen su objetivo el objetivo de los
rebeldes unidos en coalición era evitar
unos comicios que denuncian ilegítimos
por ello ofrecieron un alto el fuego
unilateral de 72 horas que cancelaron un
día después ante la negativa del
gobierno de posponer las elecciones dado
el clima hostil los centroafricanos
temen recoger sus tarjetas electorales
ante el recuerdo de una guerra civil que
entre 2013 y 2014 causó miles de muertos
por ésta huyeron 49 millones de
ciudadanos de los que 675 mil siguen
fuera y no podrán votar si quiso para
cook y muy pocos electores tienen la
posibilidad de desplazarse el domingo
para votar pese a las afirmaciones que
oigo no creo que la autoridad electoral
pueda desplegar el material en las 5 mil
400 mesas continúa animando a la
población para que vote ésta debe ir
masivamente para sacar a
y por eso voy a dar ejemplo es la
segunda vez que do lo que le ha aspira a
vencer a tú a ver a que a su vez ha
indicado que los grupos intentaron un
golpe de estado mediante el expresidente
fans guapos y se sea cierto o no el
asunto alcanza las manos de la comunidad
internacional mientras rusia ha dado
refuerzos militares al gobierno la onu
ha desplegado cascos azules sobre los
que ya se han registrado muertes